ce n'est pas encore jour de rentrée
scolaire pour les enfants de chelsea la
hache qui se dit bien contente de la
décision de reporter le début des
classes de près d'un mois
je suis vraiment soulagée qu'ils vont
commencer à la fin de septembre
je sais que leurs écoles vont prendre et
les touts les écoles dans gala on rêve
on prend toutes les précautions
possibles comme sony kingston aurait
bien voulu revoir leurs amis gates mais
ils disent qu'il en va du bien être de
leurs grands parents
s'il ya une éclosion explique kingston
on peut infecter nos parents qui peuvent
ensuite contaminer nos grands parents
qui peuvent en mourir
les 800 élèves des trois écoles de
gannat wagué des écoles primaires et
secondaires vont donc tous entrés en
classe de façon très progressive
un groupe d'âge à la fois en commençant
par les plus jeunes nous informer avant
et dans les écoles pour les supporter
donc tout tout ce qu'on fait c'est
vraiment basé sur une collaboration
communautaire mais y'aura pas plus que
12 enfants par classe donc deux bulles
de 6 et non n'a pas choisi de suivre ce
que
ministère de l'éducation a sorti
dernièrement dans son plan donc on va
maintenir l'idée des bulles les masques
seront est requis dans les corridors en
tout déplacement de théâtre au practice
est le centre de l'éducation veut
pratiquer de nouvelles routines de
distanciation physique de l'autobus
scolaire jusqu'à l'entrée en classe avec
chaque groupe
avant de commencer l'enseignement
question de modifier au besoin les
pratiques et de prendre le pouls des
enseignants parallèlement les casinos
les bars demeure fermé à gannat wagué la
petite communauté de quelques 7000
personnes préfèrent être vigilantes
même si elle n'a répertorié aucun cas
positif depuis trois mois
urso nous on a pris des mesures très tôt
dès le début de l'éclosion à l'étranger
on n'a pas attendu le gouvernement du
québec pour fermé nos écoles nos
commerces et on continue d'être prudent
parce que tout le monde ici à beth
ensemble les enfants les parents les
aînés explique le responsable de la
sécurité publique
golombek rugby rugby un exemple je pense
que gana wagué peut être un exemple pour
tous
un exemple positif conclut chelsea ici
julie marceau radio-canada ghana wang